[Music]
while scamming in jamaica brings in
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
scamming in israel is reported to bring
in billions
i want to know how it works
what's happening you can see him
okay everyone ready he's driving up guys
so i arranged to meet with a man who was
described to me as a big player
in the scamming industry i'm told he's
made a fortune running various
investment companies
all of which specialize in financial
fraud
i was also told to be very careful
hi hello thank you so much for meeting
us i'm marianna
moshiko you have a phone i do about to
help you
okay i don't want to be trucked so
you're going to turn it off just do it
to me i'll take care of it
okay
i've interviewed hundreds of people
through the years
moshik was the first to ever take away
my phone
i asked him to give me the scammer store
of tel aviv
we're in the lima gun an area known as
the diamond district
buildings like this and all these
skyscrapers you see
they have hundreds and hundreds of
people that go to work each day
selling fake investments to people
around the world
in a lot of these buildings that look
completely legitimate there's actually
all this
many of the companies there are just
fake scams with a name that makes them
look real
no one knows what's going on behind
closed door is it an open secret you
seem to know do people in
tel aviv and israel no no they don't
want to attract attention
they don't want reporters calling them
it's a massive massive fraud they want
to be under the radar
how many of these companies fraudulent
scamming companies do you think they are
israel yeah no way
holy while the lottery scam in jamaica
is the go-to con
in israel it's all about the investment
scam
the depth of this fraud was first
uncovered by simona wineglass
an investigative journalist who was
tipped off by a source working at a scam
investment company he told me that there
wasn't just
one company like this but there were
hundreds and they were stealing billions
of dollars it sounded
crazy it turned out to be true just like
in jamaica
simona says the investment scams in
israel often start with call centers and
lead lists
employees at these seemingly legitimate
companies
cold call potential clients and get them
to invest
in an exciting trading opportunity you
start to trade
you'll see your account going up and up
the retention agent will keep talking to
you and getting you to put more and more
money in
and then eventually when they sense that
you're not going to put any more money
in
they just disappear with the money
[Music]
you